foreign
we often encounter situations where we
feel like buying our own house but
sometimes it becomes a little too
expensive but you buy it anyway well to
make that happen you need to borrow a
loan from the bank so you put up a down
payment of 20 percent so you can borrow
the rest of the 80 percent from the bank
and make the payments and if you fail to
make the payment to the bank they can
easily confiscate the house now what
exactly happens is the bank lends you
money knowing that you will pay high
interest on it and then the banks give
that interest to its lenders of course
after having their profiting charges
well Ave is a cryptocurrency version of
that bank well hello everyone and
welcome to this new video of Simply
learn on what is Ave in this video you
will explore what is Ave and following
that you will see how exactly Ave came
into existence and then you will see how
it works and after that you'll see some
real life usages of Ave and at the end
you will explore whether it is safe or
not but before moving ahead please do
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more such interesting videos and hit
that Bell icon so you never miss an
update from Simply learn now moving on
to what is Ave Ave is technically a
decentralized application that allows
people to lend and borrow
cryptocurrencies all without a middleman
in return for some fees Ave uses an
algorithm to determine the lending rates
and match the borrowers with lenders
using a smart contract smart contracts
enable these assets to be managed by a
distributed network of computers running
its software and when lenders deposit
cryptocurrency into the protocol it is
routed to a liquidity pool where it is
used to meet the demands of the
protocol's borrowers now if you're
unfamiliar with what a liquidity pool is
you can definitely see our video on
liquidity pool which will be appearing
at the top of your screen right now this
means that Ave users do not have to put
their trust in a certain institution or
individual to manage their money they
merely need to believe that the code
will run exactly as intended well now
that you know what Ave is this raises a
question of how and why it came into
existence Ave was founded by stani
kulachoff who was very interested in
ethereum and how it could disrupt
traditional Finance in November of 2017
Stanley kulachoff and a team of
developers released eathland in an
initial coin offering or Ico by letting
users publish loan requests and offers
the intention was to enable users to
lend and borrow cryptocurrency from one
another although etherland was an
Innovative concept the network and its
Associated token lend lost popularity
once the 2018 bear Market began lack of
liquidity and the difficulty in matching
loan requests to offers were the
platform's main problems in 2020
Eastland revamped its offering and
changed its name to Ave switching from
the Lend token to Ave in the process Ave
was redeemable for 100 lend for every
token as part of the migration and since
that movement the group has received
more than 32 million dollars from some
of the leading Venture capitalists in
the blockchain industry including
blockchain capital and standard crypto
so now that you know the functionality
and the motive of Ave let me take you
through the workings of Ave to make you
understand how it fulfills its motive so
the first step is to submit of a request
for comment or Arc the post should
provide all the details of the
potentially final AIP when an arc is
submitted on the governance Forum as a
result the community will have the
opportunity to offer suggestions for
improvement and if a general consensus
can be reached through a community poll
to successfully submit and vote on the
AIP now following that the second step
is to create a snapshot all queries and
remarks are addressed after being placed
on the governance Forum in order to
enhance the arc to get input from the
community and choose the preferred
course a snapshot vote is advised this
quick view enables a general agreement
to be reached to increase the likelihood
that the AIP submission will succeed and
then comes the last step which is to
submit an of a request for improvement
or AIP a GitHub pull request is used to
submit the suggestion and the community
decides whether to approve it moving on
let me take you through some of the real
life uses of Ave first is security users
can stake the Ave erc20 token to help
secure the system and receive
compensation in return second is
collateral borrowers who pledge the
native token as security for their loans
are required to pay lower costs than
those who utilize other cryptocurrencies
that are locked within the platform and
the third one is Dao Ave serves as the
Dow's governance token and can be used
to cast votes on proposals about the
addition of additional tokens to the
protocol platform functionality and
other uses well this was all about Ave
but wait one question remains unanswered
is are they safe well Ave a
decentralized money market paves the
path for a more transparent and open
Financial system Ave is an intriguing D5
project that enables transparent access
to funds and services for Bitcoin users
another encouraging advancement is the
Ave token it gives its owners the power
to change the Ave protocol the procedure
is additionally safeguarded from Black
Swan situations so now this was all
about Ave and if you found this video
interesting and informative please do
hit the like button and subscribe to our
YouTube channel simply learn if you have
any questions regarding this video
please feel free to ask away in our
comments section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here